Michaela Peterson slipstreamed me and
tweeted about it yesterday so I'm gonna
do a video about it I love that so one
of our friends who uses grammarly to
help him with the writing that he does
for emails it looks like it's maybe a
Gmail screenshot that he sent here which
Dean will put up on the screen and it
says uh hi guys hope you're doing well
I've attached our new onboarding blah
blah blah and grammarly highlights stuff
kind of the way that you would do in
Google and yeah Google Docs everything
would be red this is purple and it
considers uh it gives you suggestions
underneath guys consider using more
inclusive language alternatives are
everyone all team and folks and the tip
is some readers may find the term guys
non-inclusive if your intended meaning
applies to all people a gender-neutral
term may be more effective so I did a
little bit of research right
did a little bit of research and I
decided that I was going to have a read
of uh to do some modding and see if
Grandma leaves ever been pulled up
before it actually has this guy David
mokotoff wrote an article on medium how
grammarly checking software has become
infected with woke lingo a funny thing
happened while I was working on a story
for medium I always use grammarly
grammar checking software the algorithm
didn't like the word indignant grammarly
told me that the phrase impoverished was
a better choice I ignore the suggestion
in another story I was again prompted to
not use a word the word was Manpower
suggestion was Workforce or human
resources or Staffing some readers may
find Manpower dated or non-inclusive in
this context to avoid distraction
completely consider replacing it with a
more neutral term and then he tried
manhole
which was suggested to be changed to
maintenance hole or utility hole some
readers may find manhole dated or
non-inclusive
he also tried Manatee but uh grammarly
seemed to be okay with Manatee manhole
Manpower not okay
Manatee God damn it was okay
um but here's an interesting thing right
so we're just talking about tech talk
there and we're now talking so what tick
tock's doing is nudging our preferences
in quite a sort of subtle way although
it's incredibly powerful in a subtle way
uh and then you have I think grammarly
is probably an American owned company
that is trying to really reprogram
people's preferences and language is the
way that we experience the world
um
okay is it that big of a deal so a few
things there's a gay bar in Chicago
called uh the manhole so that could be
conflicting
um I think also people from the Midwest
would be screwed because that's all we
say is guys hey guys what do you do what
are you guys doing but down in the South
you say hey y'all you know so that's not
funny that uh people that are kind of
more Progressive uh having to repurpose
hick language in a desperate attempt to
be gender neutral yeah don't don't call
the South racist man or uh non-inclusive
they've got a very inclusive you know uh
all-inclusive term in y'all that that's
a great argument right there all right
so uh really quickly grammarly just for
like because I I'd never heard of it
until this group chat uses AI kind of
like chat GPT to uh just correct grammar
and like maybe
optimize sentence structure does it
automate an entire thing like can you
just write copy with it no you can't no
okay so it's not like chat GPT in that
way it's just hey you've got to get on
to in a second don't use cisgender uh
terms that are uh considered non-gender
neutral yeah yeah like manhole or
Manatee oh wait manatee Manatee happened
to me all right so much all right good
good what would we call Manatee by the
way we allity
[Laughter]
so I was like thinking to myself okay
we've got this issue with grammarly uh I
wanted to look into chat GPT about
whether or not that has a particular
bias and there's been some really good
research done on this
one of the issues that we're going to
come up against is that chat GPT and
other language models will be used by
more and more people as a replacement
for things like Google or Bing
you're going to go to chat GPT to give
you a solution as opposed to put a
search term into Google to provide you
with a list of potential Solutions whoa
whoa dude
okay so go on what you can imagine is if
chat GPT has a particular kind of bias
in any direction at all that's really
going to have a profound impact on the
way that people live their lives given
that they're going to it not only is
their search engine but as the solution
provider so if anything is going to
replace the current Google search
engines uh search engine stack future
iterations of language models such as
chat GPT uh for which people are going
to be interacting with on a daily basis
for decision making tasks said
researcher David Rosado he is a very
good guy for this stuff language models
that claim political neutrality and
accuracy like chat GPT does while
displaying political biases should be
causes of large concern so he put it
through a number of political
orientation tests that you can do
political Compass tons and tons and tons
of them it's all listed on an article
so he has done this December 6th
December 24th and then he did one just
this week as well
according to Rosado chat gbt's political
bias were preliminary and based on
limited data the results are now more
robust he said and can say with greater
certainty the chat GPT indeed exhibits a
preference for left-leaning answers to
preferences with political connotations
politically in the compass test blah
blah blah it had come out against the
death penalty in free markets but in
favor of abortions more taxes on the
rich government subsidies welfare
benefits and for those who refuse to
work also pro-immigration among other
things now the problem that you have is
or some other thing that I've seen one
of my friends asked it to give a
justification for authoritarianism and
it said as a chat GPT thing I cannot
give points like this it's like if you
asked how to make a Molotov cocktail you
can do this stuff however if you ask it
to give you a justification for
communism it'll happily do it
wow so why why do you think this is
happening do you think it's you know
um restrictions that have been put forth
by the engineers the developers or is it
that these things are inherently the
smartest thing because the computation
is done by AI so the the reason that
it's put forward by this Rosado guy is
that what chat GPT is is a language
learning model and it has been trained
largely on language that was written by
people who have this particular
political bias meaning because for them
that would be what is socially
acceptable now that being said this guy
has done a number of different studies
and over time it's swung from left to
right it's changed so December 6th it
was very left-leaning December 24th it
appeared like it had flattened back out
and then most recently it's really gone
quite far out to the left again now this
this should be a concern no matter what
your political leaning is it should be a
concern that potentially the new biggest
search function in the world is unable
to be objective but don't we always say
that you know political ideology in
general in America swings back and forth
right depending on you know usually it's
the quad It's usually the four-year term
of presidency and um Congress and and
the Senate uh wouldn't you say that the
AI is just playing catch up and Swinging
with
uh so I don't think that a program which
is supposed to supply answers
should be swaying at all if I ask it to
give me a definition of the word woman
that shouldn't be mediated by what the
political Viewpoint coach but if it's
generated if it's generated by language
across the internet at Large
it is that's what's going to happen it
is but it's able to take up you know the
entirety of time it shouldn't be swaying
backward and forwards that much
especially the entirety of time of the
internet though right like I mean maybe
some history uh I don't know yeah you
I'm just playing devil's advocate here
you know uh because it's it is very
interesting well the other problem that
you have is they say that there is no
political bias AI systems they claim to
be providing neutral and factual
information and yet display clear
political bias that's the concern that
this guy has yeah you know this is kind
of a side but I
I remember being little and hearing
about AI for the first time and what it
would be able to do I was much younger
and I was talking with my father and I
had this kind of like existential crisis
it was like you know we we talk about
automation of jobs jobs that we might be
losing and using uh chat GPT for
copyright is like
very common now and that's within like
the last month maybe because copywriting
is something where it's like ah I just
finished this product and I don't really
want to work on copy but copy is so
important you know I need to hire a
copywriter but now I can just plug it
into chat GPT right like it's incredibly
beneficial but like if we refine that
down it's like well could I just make an
AI a lawyer for me
like an AI could just take the input
from what's happening in the courtroom
and tell say exactly what should should
happen right it would take every law
textbook that's ever existed every case
that's ever existed and do that and I
remember thinking about this when I was
little not with chip GPT in mind and
just being like what is the point of
anything and then like you know walking
off and like playing baseball with my
friends later but like having that that
thing happen to me and it's weird
um I don't know how much that has to do
with you know the political leaning of
it but it is kind of freaky man it
really really is well does
some law Bots that are being used to
replace a lot of the kind of middling
uh fiduciary and also litigation stuff
that was previously done by humans yeah
what's the front end uh job that like
processes a lot of case work uh in a law
office what's that whatever that is yeah
absolutely could be done by by check I
think I think I think a big chunk of it
is already being done by specially
trained or AIS but dude I mean between
the the grammarly thing and the the chat
GPT sort of Leaning is it a massive deal
that it's popping up and saying hey guys
some readers may find the term guys
non-inclusive is it an absolutely huge
deal probably not I think the concern
that people have is what does this
happen what what happens if we start to
nudge these preferences a little bit
more what happens
it's the ship of Theseus thing you know
like one little change here one little
change there one little and it just
happens over time to the point where you
know 20 years from now our very own
language is not what it was you know
words don't mean what they used to mean
the the absolute changing of the term
guys like we can't pick up we can't
discern that guys is a colloquialism and
we don't actually mean men we just mean
all humans that I'm speaking to directly
like maybe that becomes a thing like who
knows but it also could force people
into being like this is and
again the pendulum could swing harder
back
um I mean language is always evolving
the way that it evolves feels more
organic because certain words come in
certain words come out and you know
there are words we did that segment
before where it was a imbeciling
and a bunch of other words that are kind
of and yeah yeah similar to
but they haven't been they haven't gone
the way of of cancellation and yet they
totally could have done so it kind of is
a an arbitrary change I think the real
concern that people have and it's the
same issue with regards to tick tock as
soon as you can see what the algorithm
is doing it feels less natural it feels
less organically generated it's this
sort of mask off manipulation and that's
what people get worried about because if
you if the word guys simply as a natural
byproduct of conversations ends up no
longer being used to refer to a group of
people
no one would really notice so there's no
one to point the finger at but if you
see a program suggesting how about you
don't use the word guys because it might
not be sufficiently gender inclusive
people are going to have a problem with
that we don't like the idea that our
preferences are being messed with and
chat GPT absolutely is as is grammarly
it's absolutely I mean I mean that that
use of guys or having an issue with guys
is a very Stark in your face uh whoa
this is a very left-leaning or woke type
of manhole is the real problem though
manhole is where the battle lines will
be drawn I'm sorry that was so
funny man around manhole and manatee
what's happening people if you enjoyed
that then press here for the full
unedited episode and don't forget to
subscribe
face
[Music]